if you love Avatar The Last Airbender
here are five other titles that are
definitely worth checking out on this
week's binge guide made for kids but
doesn't shy away from hard themes Avatar
The Last Airbender is bringing all three
of its 100% fresh seasons the Netflix
after what feels like a hundred years
sleep it's filled with compelling
characters incredible world building and
storylines and if you're a fan of the
show or its spin-off The Legend of Korra
here's some other things you're gonna
want to bend starting with our certified
fresh' pick samurai jack this series
about a young prince who is sent through
time and fighting to return home to save
the world
as many of the same action futuristic
elements that avatar fans will love with
an average audience scores 95 percent
and the fifth and final season coming
and certified fresh' in a hundred
percent critics call samurai jag
beautifully animated action-packed and
overall compelling you can slice and
dice your way through all five seasons
in just under 26 hours and after that
you'll definitely know Jack the brand
new pick for this week is Star Wars the
Clone Wars seventh and final season
which recently wrapped up on Disney Plus
on a satisfying conclusion to this story
of a Yoda Anakin and a Jedi Knights
fighting in the Clone Wars bridging the
gap between episodes two and three of
the live-action Star Wars films critics
praised the series for the same reason
avatar fans who loved it beautifully
animated action sequences and
impressively layered storytelling well
it will take you 60 hours to VIN to the
whole series just think about how many
great Star Wars nuggets you'll have as
conversation starters at the next party
you go to whenever we get to go to
parties again next up is our throwback
pic Dragon Ball Z this series which
aired in North America from 1996 to 2003
follows a warrior named Goku and his
friends who protect Earth from various
invaders while searching for seven
magical spheres avatar fans will
appreciate this true anime in its purest
form while critics have praised it for
the awesome battles and satisfying story
elements you're in for a long binge in
just under off
and 11 hours to get through the series
but at least you'll come away from it
knowing that earth was well protected
emerging as our under the radar pick
this week is vrock and the princesses of
power this remake of an 80s cartoon is
about an orphan girl Shira who is
transformed into a warrior by magic
sword and leads a rebellion to free her
land from monstrous invaders much like
Avatar
Shiro doesn't downplay hard themes for
the sake of its audience and critics say
attacks a powerful visual punch that
hits even harder thanks to layered
writing and multi-dimensional characters
with the 5th and final season just
landing on Netflix it'll take you 26
hours to finish the series so better get
to it and finally our editors picks this
week is Teen Titans
this show features DC characters Robin
Starfire Raven cyborg and Beast Boy and
proves that you're never too young to
save the planet also experiencing things
that normal teens face today much like
Avatar this show is tailor-made for fans
of fantasy action while critics have
praised it for blending pop art
animation with surprisingly heavy themes
with a vintage time of just over 25
hours this shows an enduring favorite
and will make you appreciate Robin as
much more than just Batman's sidekick
okay if I've done my job hopefully this
will help guide you through your next
viewed in session be sure to check back
here for future recommendations and
ideas based around the TV and movies
that you love right here on the Rotten
Tomatoes binge guide
[Music]
you